hey guys it's Justine and today I
partnering with Apollo nuro to show you
a super unique and interesting device in
the world of wearable tech this is the
Apollo and it's all about Good
Vibrations now at first glance you might
think that this is some kind of Fitness
tracker but you would be very mistaken
rather than tracking your health the
Apollo wearable is meant to actively
improve it the Apollo wearable
transforms how you feel through your
sense of touch using soothing quiet
vibrations it's kind of like music that
your body can feel let's unbox this and
I'll show you what I mean so here it is
inside the box we have the Apollo
wearable itself a band a clip and of
course a USB charging cable so to put it
on you can wear it around your wrist or
your ankle or you can use the clip to
attach Apollo to your shirt bra or
waistband it does come with this one
medium-size band which should fit most
people but they also have larger and
smaller bands available if needed what I
really love is there's multiple ways to
wear this so you can experiment and try
different placements depending upon
what's most comfortable for you now for
me I have been wearing this on my ankle
for the most part because I already have
a watch on one wrist I usually wear a
bracelet on the other wrist and a lot of
times when I'm filming I wear a
microphone that is like clipped right
here to my bra so all of these areas are
taken but guess what my ankle is all
free and I also like this because a lot
of times I can cover it with my sock or
my pants so it's super discreet more of
them wearing shorts and low socks it's
actually a really fun conversational
starter where people are like what is
that on your your ankle what what is
that so it's been really fun to explain
to them what it does now what's really
great about it is it was created by
medical professionals and
neuroscientists and it has actually been
proven to help improve areas like Sleep
Quality concentration heart rate
variability performance and Recovery
Apollo works with the Apollo nuro app so
let's check it out I'll show you guys
how you can customize your experience
with Apollo I have been so sporadic over
the last couple of weeks with traveling
and weird sleeping patterns and having
to be active and speaking and events and
it's been quite hectic so in the morning
when I would wake up I would use the
good morning routine here and this one
is about 90 minutes so I would use this
after I got back from the gym or if I
didn't have time to work out I would use
this sort of in replace of the gym for
that morning so I put this on while I'm
getting ready there's also a little
power naap one that I've tried a few
times and it's actually pretty
incredible I thankfully don't have
trouble taking naps or falling asleep
but I do feel like this just puts you in
sort of this very very Zen State now I
have loved using this for energy so you
can go through here you can do 5 minute
15 minute or 30 minutes so I like using
this before I have to go speak or even
film a video this is actually the
routine that I put on before I started
filming this video there's other
routines like social this one I like
because you can adjust it to up to 120
minutes so if you have to go to a dinner
or an event you can set that for a nice
120 minutes and it assists with your
social abilities you can focus recover
stay calm unwind fall asleep now I don't
use the fall asleep one every single
night but I have been using it
especially when I travel because when
I'm at home home I'm in my comfort zone
I have all of the things around me my
perfect pillows my perfect bed
temperature when I'm traveling that I
don't have so I've used this a ton to
help me fall asleep while traveling now
I'm someone who really struggles to
focus so unless I'm editing or writing
emails I'm listening to audiobooks to
kind of keep my mind trained and focused
on the audiobook while I do other tasks
and since I can't listen to audiobooks
when I'm editing and doing other types
of tasks I've been using this in its
replacement and it's been super helpful
mostly because has just like this gentle
vibration where it's kind of it's really
hard to explain but I kind of link it to
like when you go to the doctors and they
give you a shot a lot of times the nurse
will like tap on my arm or tap on my
shoulder and before I know it like it's
done so it seems like it's a slight
distraction but for me specifically it's
almost aiding in my focus like I don't
know if that makes any sense but for me
that's kind of what it's been and it's
been really incredible now why I was so
interested in testing this out is
because the science behind this
technology is the real deal their
research shows that users experienced up
to 40% less stress and feelings of
anxiety on average up to 19% more time
in deep sleep and up to 25% more focus
and concentration now it's interesting
because I do have the ability to track
all of these things with various sleep
trackers that's something that I've been
kind of working on to see how my various
sleep scores and fitness scores track
over time so I can't wait to kind of go
through and see this when I have all the
data available now overall if think
Apollo is a really great device in the
world of wearable health and fitness
Tech but the Apollo truly is something
very different it's not a fitness
tracker trackers are great for Gathering
data over time so you can see your
health Trends and what you might need to
do to feel better but this device
actually makes you feel better now I
haven't really seen anything like this
and for me it's actually been really
beneficial over the last few weeks of
using it I think if anyone is interested
in lowering stress or just increasing
those Good Vibes this is definitely
something that you might want to check
out and try for yourself click the link
in my description to save up to $70 off
during Apollo's Black Friday Cyber
Monday sale happening November 17th to
the 27th let me know what you guys think
about the Apollo in the comments below
and is this something that you would
want to try out I'd love to hear it
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next video bye